welcome welcome to this video Capaldi
Capaldi I never played this guy let me
check he's got 1,100 in and 1400 in the
other in the other rating pool 1703
minute and this is a second two-minute
game okay yeah maybe he just he just won
two games it can happen and let's see
what happens in this in this this game
you get a very big rating boosts in the
first two games in them in the in the
pools so it can it's possible that he
just beat like me look at this he won no
it's been a while that he played those
five-minute games but okay it's it's
totally possible that he beat him to
lower rated players to get to this big
rating it's taking a really long time
him we have a check Benoni on the board
an opening where black is accepting
disadvantage in space and he wants to
outmaneuver the opponent long-term the
Bishop g5 is a very typical way to
proceed but it is I think not very well
timed here because I have this f4 f4
idea that makes sure that I'm not
actually I'm not actually allowing the
trade note Knight e5 as an interesting
move
to cover him I can send the night back
with with h3 I guess Queen h4 maybe or
f5 them it's not that's not totally it's
not clear or interesting so if I go h3
night back to f6 then rook f3 or
something I guess I should do that
aha
interesting so if I take Knight takes a
my mate it I don't see it not at all
Queen edge talking of one how I met
chick made it I don't see it takes
Knight takes rook f3 Queen edge -
checking of one we need strong maybe
even I don't know I don't see how I'm
checkmated here
I see able to play for a long-term
attack here with a fire for something
like that would be really remarkable no
one's going to age - okay I cannot play
rook h3
this is covered yeah maybe I should play
Queen you won or something like that
what I can move the rook I mean he's is
he threatening something not so much I
can go to g3 just like terribly
irritating to have the night on h2 but
okay so I thought Queenie one is aloof
if he moves the bishop then this rook g7
winning in the Queen
I think he really is just material down
there is only at five yeah only f5 can
be a problem
FF probably five can also move the
Rockaway trying to treat Queens I'm
actually trading Queen Sarah the smooth
walk win age five I can go Queen each
fiber denied g3m it's all kind of weird
Knight f5 or is this bad night f5 for
the Queen trade finally check dropping
I'm dropping a pony on f4 but ok it's
not a big it didn't happen and it
wouldn't have been a big problem anyway
ok yeah that's just straight stuff and
win with with the extra piece hopefully
hopefully get the knight black into
business him mmm
then give the chick but I can take it
and I want to go 94 95 yep black resigns
yeah I only got 2 points for this game
because he was a provisional you rated
player he did a good job really if you
look at his ratings he's really like
terribly low rated and some pools one
minute is like 1100 but 3 minute is 1800
which is not that bad at all so he
really did a good job here hanging on
and making yeah at least irritating me
quite a bit it it really isn't isn't any
good what he's doing here I think I can
really take the material and
and run so to say that it's still
irritated he corrects quite a bit the
comp is always giving like plus five
plus six whatnot yeah so it was it was
definitely okay all the way an important
point is that here this Bishop g5 move
is really not a good idea because I have
this f4 move this is one of the main
points by white plays g3 and and a 92 in
this kind of line to have f4 available
as a counter blow against the bishop
yeah I hope you enjoyed this video
thanks for watching